thank you
hey everybody and welcome to a radical
wild ride with Stevo this guy might be
the raddest dude we've ever had on it's
Niger Houston I understand that he's the
highest paid skateboarder on Earth I
happen to love wearing his Nike shoes I
mean seriously these are my favorite
shoes to skate in and uh man was I
excited for this conversation like so
much I wanted to ask him about about
riding for element at the same time as
Bam Margera about like all this just
crazy stuff man it's so exciting and
what a bro Niger is he said he'll do the
podcast but only if I go to his premiere
for his new part to launch his third
Nike shoe I'm like are you kidding me
like hell yeah I'll go to your Premiere
it was so nuts man he's just put out two
of the craziest video parts
maybe the two craziest video Parts ever
and uh I'm I'm telling this to Thrasher
right now if Nigel's not skater of the
Year this year I'm out I'm done with you
so let's get into it
ladies and gentlemen Niger Houston yeah
dude so this is Scott Randolph you guys
actually met when we came to your
facility yeah with the uh the skate
mobile yeah when we were when I when you
were skating my car oh yeah we're
skating the car yeah damn that [ __ ] was
tight and we met at the tattoo shop
afterwards right you got the crow tattoo
that when did you get that Crow tattoo
on my neck yeah no I got that one out in
Texas oh really a while back yeah I went
to a tattoo shop after yeah damn my
memory is shot I don't remember what
though that's the one thing I remember
my memory is [ __ ] bro too many
concussions it's crazy but yeah I
remember like it it was really awkward I
felt it was really awkward because for
some reason I had it in my head that you
had been the the skater of the year or I
think you were the current skater of the
year so like I've got my my dude [ __ ]
filming me and I'm like introducing you
as like the the Thrasher skater of the
year and like I didn't even realize you
know like and I don't know if it came
off like I was [ __ ] you know like I
was joking or like or whatever I just
was just an ignorant [ __ ] [ __ ] oh
yeah no no scared of the year yet but
dude
yeah this well here's the thing dude it
is to me so [ __ ] insulting that
you've never been Thrasher skater of the
year like honestly I I hear that from a
lot of people I hear it from you know a
lot of kids and fans and stuff I don't
really agree because I mean yeah I mean
I've been putting out video Parts I've
been Street skating for so long now so
it's easy for people to kind of see it
that way but most of the time when
people get Skate of the year you can
tell they really dedicate one year to
getting that in one year to putting out
like a lot of footage in a like a
smaller amount of time
um I mean I've put out a ton of footage
footage this year but the previous years
yeah I've had some gnarly video Parts
the till death Nike part that's the
burliest part yeah but like I I never
really like tried to get it that's the
thing you know a lot of times when
people get it they are like really like
going for it they're really gunning for
it I thought you were gonna say that uh
you know when the
they've put so much emphasis on skating
like everything you know and and like
maybe I would I thought you were gonna
say that you don't skate enough
transition no like I mean I've been
following obviously like through Asher
and the guys who have gotten skate of
the year for since I was a little kid
and back in the day I feel like it was
different like I feel like back some
years ago you could get away with just
having like maybe one or two like really
gnarly video parts
but nowadays like you really have to go
in you really have to put in like minute
so many minutes of footage and have like
at least like three to four video parts
and that's that that that's a a very
healthy and humble attitude about it
because on your behalf I can say that I
am [ __ ] furious okay thank you thank
you thank you yeah dude I think it's
ridiculous but um so dude
I don't want to rehash like uh stuff
that's that's out there so much but but
with with you in your first big part the
element video elementality and you're an
AM and your little kid and you get the
last part in the video yeah like
it's that's so crazy and and what year
was that video was that 2005. that was
probably 2 000 yeah either four or five
yeah and and so at that time bam is on
element he's like the king of the world
with the [ __ ] Viva La Bam that show
made him such a star like I forget
someone like said that she was like
ranked as like I mean like Beyond like
A-list [ __ ] he was like that big of a
deal so
at that time did you have a relationship
with bam being on an element with him no
I think I just met him a couple times I
I'd obviously seen a lot of his videos
and me being the kid I was with my my
dad always being around my dad was very
protective and a very strict dad and I
think actually
my dad didn't even want me watching some
of the band videos because he knew how
just like hectic and crazy he was right
so me being like this shy kid and like
on tours with bam and like going to the
demos and stuff I was like I was kind of
like maybe even like scared of him like
intimidated I was like damn this guy's
[ __ ] nuts like I don't know what's up
with this guy
um but but part of me at the same time
was obviously a fan because I knew how
big he was and also knew that he was a
sick skater like that switched back to
you Tampa
[Laughter]
but uh it's just crazy man like that and
you were what like 11 years old at that
time
yeah around like 10 11 years old and you
got the the last part and I mean it's a
big deal in skateboard videos like
whoever gets the last part like yeah
yeah and I was aware of that as a kid
too because I was like the biggest skate
nerd ever like I I was really even
though I was so young I was really aware
of like everything that went on in
skateboarding in the skate industry you
know who who's on what sponsors what
tricks have been done on what spots like
I I seriously knew everything because I
read every single magazine and I watched
every single video like I was really
about that life sure
um and
yeah I mean having the last part like I
almost felt weird having the last part
because I had just got on the team
pretty soon before that right and I I
definitely remember some people hating
on it because I mean I I mean I
understand like if I watched some video
if I watched like some big video today
and then I had saw this little kid have
the last part I'd be like oh what the
hell like what did he do to deserve that
you know I mean right I mean who else
was on element at that time with like
Reese Forbes was on there Rhys Forbes
yeah he's the one who actually got me on
right yeah yeah he's such a rad dude do
you have your own board when you start
writing for element He was an AM when he
got that yeah this is actually the cool
part is so my dad was also very
knowledgeable on skateboarding for a dad
you know how a lot of dads yeah Skate
dads they act like they know what's good
they act like they know what tricks
their son should be doing and stuff but
they really don't know
my dad actually did know and he that's
one of the reasons why I was like
introduced to proper Street skating at
such a young age I mean I was literally
out filming with my dad like seven years
old he had me take my helmet off and
like filming Street Clips at UC Davis
well right I saw that that in the uh the
barracks life on video yeah yeah he said
you did your first handrail front board
on uh like a six star handrail and your
dad says yeah that was cool but now do
it without the helmet I'll take helmet
off yeah I think that's so sick yeah for
sure it's [ __ ] crazy honestly because
I picture when I I'm gonna have kids one
day and if my son
was Street skating at seven years old I
would want him to have a helmetro seven
is so [ __ ] young seven sir young your
brain's not developed like why did he
want you to do that just to be like
you're fully committing to this or like
you're not gonna fall or just it was the
next year it was a mixture of him
knowing that like I would get much more
respect for what I'm doing with the
helmet off and he'd be like oh like
you're like the sponsors everyone's
gonna be way more hyped on this and then
also probably just him wanting to raise
me to be a beast
that he let you pull it with the helmet
on saw that you had it and felt
comfortable that you weren't gonna slam
because you had a dial yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah so he cared enough to to have
you do it first with the helmet and then
said take it off so that that that's rad
and uh I mean dude it's it's just so let
me ask you this
Tony Hawk as I understand it has the
world Guinness World Record for winning
the most skate contests okay like you've
got to have dusted that by now yeah I
don't know I wonder how many how many
that is right I mean
do you have I don't know a total contest
so we'd have to really dig deep to go
back and remember all those
um I know like the Street Leagues I
think it's 20 maybe 22 23 something like
that
um X Games it's like 13 gold medals
um yeah but a bunch of other random ones
too yeah I I I wonder I mean it's
probably like different era sticks the
contests are just on such a different
level yeah I'm glad to know who's had
more surgeries between the two of you
guys
ah bro first surgery
wow three months ago first one ever on
your knee yeah
ACL first surgery first surgery broken
bones never broke bones
no [ __ ] wow it's crazy I think that
really is crazy that means you're really
good at skating right I mean I I can't
believe it took me this long to have a
gnarly injury like this I mean yeah I've
been injured plenty of times in the past
but it was never anything that major the
worst thing was like really bad ankle
sprains and bruised heels and stuff is
that because you take such a good care
of your body with you know I saw the the
third gun everywhere you said you do the
fair gun like three to eight times a day
I mean it's it's a mixture of a few
things all right we'll really get into
it here so I was I was raised vegan and
like very healthy for the first 16 years
of my life because my dad was very
strict about not eating meat straight
last jafarians straight Rasta [ __ ] yeah
like no soda I mean even I don't really
think it's because being vegan because
I'm not vegan nowadays I do think being
being vegan is like healthy but I think
it more so has to do with like not a lot
of sugar we didn't drink soda as a kid
no candy no ice cream stuff like that
and my mom was just cooking healthy
homemade meals so just like solid food
and then also thinking about think about
how much impact my body was taking when
I was that young so so my bones are for
sure like dense as [ __ ] so they probably
just don't want to break and then also
it has to do with me just being the type
of like skateboarder that I am and the
type of person that I am because yeah I
mean I I send send my body down all this
crazy [ __ ]
but I'm a very I'm a very like precise
and like calculated skater like I don't
just show up to it to some like 20 30
rail be like all right all right guys
I'm I'm all hyped up like I'm just gonna
go for it right here like I'm like I'm
rolling up I'm putting a lot of thought
into what I'm doing and I think that's
the main reason why it took me so long
to have a bad injury
yeah dude yeah it's not so so uh and
pardon my ignorance but rastafar
Rastafari that's a religion Rastafarian
yeah Rastafarian and and in uh the
Rastafarian religion like smoking weed
is part of the deal oh yeah a big big
part of this religious ceremony right
yeah yeah so so uh your dad had like
this this super healthy like everything
but like did he want you to smoke weed
no he actually caught me smoking weed
when I was
I was just living with him and my little
sister at the time I didn't have my
brothers around so I was just like bored
as [ __ ] I didn't know what to do with
myself a lot of the time because I
didn't really have friends either and he
caught me smoking weed one day I was
like smoking one of his little little
old little joints
and he was pissed and
he was just someone who got got easily
got pissed at me and my siblings about
things but I remember thinking like bro
like how do you ex how are you gonna get
mad at me when you've been blowing weed
smoke in my face since I was a baby like
how does that make sense like yeah yeah
and that's the dreads that what the
decision to cut the dreads was that a
heavy decision because it's it's kind of
like a you know it was it was but that
was also like a year after I hadn't seen
my dad because my parents got divorced I
hadn't seen my mom in a while my mom got
custody and then at that point I was
finally able to like kind of live my own
life and be my own person you know have
friends actually like have fun with my
life and being a skateboarder and about
a year after that I remember it was just
kind of a random decision I think I was
like skating the barracks one day I was
filming a battle commander and
in the middle of filming it I was just
like dude like I just I can't do it
anymore these things are just too
[ __ ] long and they're just always in
my face how long did you grow them out
for 16 years 16 years yeah wow yeah
because the the in the in the rastafire
religion is no razors no there's like
three things that you know the way you
don't so it was your entire lifetime of
hair yeah
did you just you just got up and did it
yeah it was one night I just did it
because I just felt like it was time for
something new and sure it really was
hard to deal with those things like I
mean like one or two more years and I
would have been Landing my tricks and
rolling them over wow dude that's crazy
and you cut them off on camera no not
even on camera I didn't even give a [ __ ]
I was just like ah these things have had
their had their time right so then there
was a video part where some of you had
dreads and then the dreads were gone it
was like yeah yeah like halfway through
the part the judge were gone
this is my element that was
element rise and shine that was just the
video of me right kind of like coming
back into the into the scene yeah that
the whole Puerto Rico thing is is nuts
man I mean like all this stuff about
your dad
um I mean you talk about your dad with
like such reverence you know like really
like like uh the way that he pushed you
and and how like you're talking about
your 9 10 years old and your dad's like
just pressuring you to do like 13 stared
handrails and like then pressing and
backside lip slide a 13 stare here in
real like yeah I mean that uh it's just
certain you know like I almost have
mixed feelings about that because then
what's like the helmet coming off take
off your helmet do a 13 scare handrail
like in one sense it's so rad because he
made you into a beast yeah and in
another sense it's like whoa like you
were a little kid and he was like
pushing some pretty heavy yeah yeah I
know I mean I think of it the same way
it really is like a love-hate thing
because would I be the type of person
and the type of skateboarder and like
have the type of mindset that I do today
if I wasn't raised like that most likely
not but at the same time like it was
[ __ ] brutal like I I I'll always be
thankful for my dad being such a like
supportive dad on me as as being a
skater it's like for example he was a
skater back in his teenage years sure
and obviously it was at a way different
point back in like the 80s but like his
parents were like bro what the [ __ ] are
you doing like go to college or
do something with your life like why are
you playing with this toy and that's I'm
sure that's still a lot of parents these
days right so I'm thankful for that but
being that young and being pushed to do
the stuff that I did and like for
example like being at a big rail
like let's say we're like on a road trip
like an hour away from home we gotta
drive home after and
I'm just like [ __ ] like I I have to go
for it I'm like sitting there rolling up
to this rail for like an hour just
scared as [ __ ] but I'm just thinking
like I don't have an option because I'm
either gonna like send my body down this
rail and at least try to do it or he's
just gonna be pissed at me for like the
rest of the day so it's like [ __ ] every
time you went up to the rails you're
like hurry up hurry up or is he just
patient and waiting for you to not hurry
up but like he my dad carried this like
very like Stern strong demeanor and you
can just tell you can just tell by his
facial expression that you just like
dude like you just you have to go for it
you know now if anybody understands that
it can be pretty cool and radical to be
dangerous and unprotected some of the
time it's me but let's face it you never
want to be unprotected when it comes to
your personal information online that is
a fact and that is why I use
nordvpn it's a virtual private Network
that text all of my passwords all of my
data all of my information that I don't
want anybody snooping around with and
when I'm overseas I can watch the fights
I love the UFC it's because by using the
virtual private Network you create an IP
address that can place you anywhere in
the world your stealth and when you're
at home you can watch any TV programming
from the streamers from anywhere in the
world it's really cool man and if you go
to
nordvpn.com
Stevo then not only do you get a huge
discount but you get four extra months
completely for free and it's completely
risk free with their 30-day money-back
guarantee you're not happy boom you get
your refund but I'll tell you man I love
having nordvpn on all of my devices I
feel safer I feel more entertained I
just
I love it and nordvpn loves you so jump
on this deal by going to
nordvpn.com
Stevo yeah dude now let's get back to it
and you land it you look at your dad and
what does he do he's Juiced he's
probably proud he's proud yeah yeah it's
it's epic and uh but even more but even
more than that it's like like I was
saying he actually knew about skating so
it wasn't just like going to a big Rail
and like grinding it he knew that like
all right like I've seen you do like 50s
feebles and stuff down other bigger
rails so you're at this 13 rail like you
gotta you gotta like backsmith it or
something you know he really like knew
what I needed to do to like have valid
Clips in my video part right and he knew
like what tricks had been done on like
every rail too huh dared it's crazy
um man and so so then
he comes up with the idea that you're
going to move to Puerto Rico and you're
kind of bummed because you're like whoa
I mean dude California is where it's at
what are we going to Puerto Rico for
yeah and uh and and that was because he
wanted to like have a huge weed growing
operation
that was part of it I think it was I
think it was like 50 50 like being being
that being one of the reasons and then
also just trying to keep me and my
siblings as secluded as possible from
normal lifestyle because I mean that's
the way rostas think about if you're
like a true Rasta
they think about normal society as just
like
the devil just kind of yeah yeah the
devil just a lot of like brainwashing
and you know that's why I never I never
you know ate normal food growing up
never ate fast food never like watch
normal movies never went to the movies
until I was 16 just not we didn't do
like normal life things and moving to an
island like that was just another step
into taking us
into keeping us under his wing and not
being a normal family normal kids were
you at least by the ocean in Puerto Rico
were you in the middle of Puerto Rico so
for a little bit we were in like a nice
gated community which was close to the
ocean and then we lived there for a year
and then after that the next couple the
next like two or three years that I was
there we were like in the [ __ ] jungle
for sure wow like up in the mountain was
like it was literally an hour drive up
the mountain from the nearest town so
did you have to like grow your own food
and grow your own weed and you do that I
mean we we did grow some stuff yeah
Mofongo yeah he had a big weed weed farm
out there which I don't even understand
because I don't think weed grows grows
good in that Humanity right I don't know
I would think that it was fantastic I'm
pretty sure it doesn't I think it's too
wet and I think it rains too much maybe
but isn't like we grow pretty good in
Hawaii is like the same climate or no
not really no it's it's a little it's
not as hot there it's not as hot and
it's not as humid yeah okay yeah the
outdoor program I think it's tougher to
manage maybe but it's just risky yeah
with the weather and stuff because
before before going there like I was
I was raised around weed my whole life
like every house we lived in growing up
the biggest room in the house weed
plants everywhere wow like sometimes I
think you would literally be like his in
my mom's bed and then just like weed
plants just like hanging all over it
that's wild dude yeah so with the
mentality being to like
shelter you from like society and and
kind of keep you like out of all that
at the same time he's managing your
skate career
so that's got to be like
I like even for him like add-ons he
wants you to be blown up and and
successful and in the mix but he also
doesn't I know it's so weird bro these
are things like I haven't talked to him
in a lot of years now but these are the
type of things I wish I could just ask
him about because it really is confusing
like he wanted me to be this you know
big Superstar skateboarder but he wanted
it's like it's like he wanted to be he
he was a very controlling person
and he took it too far as to where like
he didn't know how to let me go on a
trip with my sponsors without him you
know he didn't know how to let me like
do anything without him being a part of
it and he filmed you like a ton in
Puerto Rico and the footage has never
went anywhere most of the footage yeah
is gone is it true that that uh it's a
lot of footage too yeah what was it a
kickflip backside lip slide down like a
gnarly yeah well sure yeah Wilshire 15 I
had the cover of skateboard mag and and
uh
dude I know so people speculate that you
didn't land that kickflip backside lip
down that handrail and you know for damn
sure you did and there's video of it but
yeah I know it's just lost the Lost
Tapes I mean yeah I landed it perfect
too yeah I was sick where are they do we
know he has them somewhere and he's in
Puerto Rico he would I I don't even know
where he's at right now but he would
never he would never give him back or I
wouldn't think so you know maybe if we
figure out how to rekindle our
relationship one day maybe we could
figure it out but like I don't know my
dad's a very uh
a very like strong like prideful person
you know he has a hard time like giving
up his pride and control on things so
he's not watching you on YouTube videos
because he probably doesn't even have a
computer he's got to be like so proud of
you that's ridiculous like I I'm also
curious if he's like super heavy into
the roster lifestyle still I don't know
man have you tried to reach out at all
no it's been a while yeah I mean but
that's almost something that like you
feel like you should do
10 years
it's been so long at this point you know
I assume that he's off like doing his
own thing and I'm sure he like has a new
family out there and stuff and I just
kind of I mean you speak about him
like I I just sense that there's so much
reverence so much respect when you speak
about it for sure yeah that uh he's got
to know that
you know you're not out there like bad
mouthing him like like you talk about
him like he's like this
you know like God to you like when you
were a kid yeah and um he's got to be so
proud of everything that you've
accomplished man yeah I mean I you know
I hope I hope he sees it that way I hope
he does I hope he sees this yeah and uh
you know like if if he were to reach out
to you I mean I guess he goes without
saying that your mom and and him aren't
in contact yeah
um yeah I don't think anyone's talked to
him for a while to be honest man but you
would be you would be open to it if he
did reach out to you I would be open to
it yeah dude epic it'd be good for the
soul yeah it's good like that's not even
closure but it's just kind of I mean
it's I think that it it would be
it seems it would be very healthy yeah
yeah actually my little brother is the
one that really wants to have a
relationship with him because he's the
most similar to my dad in that same way
where they just think about life and
just
the same way you know they just they
don't want to be a part of normal
society my little brother's like the
most chill he's actually a really sick
skater too sickest style but he's just
such like a chill just down to earth guy
just wants to like you know live on a
farm growing up grows on food and just
kick it so I'm more so wish that like
they had a relationship because I could
see like how it kind of affects his life
yeah with not having her having a
relationship with him but who knows
maybe one day we'll see how many
brothers do you have three brothers one
sister I'm the middle wow yeah
That's crazy dude and um
so you're always skating contests I mean
what's it like uh since this surgery you
said how long since the surgery it's
been like three and a half months now
three and a half months you just dropped
this part the shine on part and
like like what was the timing like based
on
uh like when most of it filmed well I'm
just saying like when like uh I mean
evidently you haven't you were sitting
on that footage for like three months
yeah no so what was the planning for the
dropping yeah that footage was a mix of
footage throughout the past couple years
me and Ty Evans have also been filming
this documentary for like three years
now that's what the premiere is tomorrow
no no no this is just another
way bigger Street part than I'm putting
out with Nike the documentary is going
to come out sometime next year but
throughout that time of filming for the
documentary me and Ty we were out street
skating so we stocked up a bunch of
footage but I wasn't able to fully
finish it how I wanted to I was I
actually tore my ACL filming for that
part I was getting this big Gap trail
and just you know got me but uh yeah we
still we still got enough footage to put
out a good part and I was I was honestly
Jesus I I was watching it
I'm like because I see uh on your
Instagram I saw that like that frontside
Smith and then that crazy like what even
was that down after yeah I mean dude it
was just like an over blunt like like an
over nose blunt kind of a thing it was
it was just nuts but I I remember seeing
that come up I'm like oh here's the
Ender because I saw you posted on
Instagram like oh okay so this is the
Ender and they're like oh dude there's
another one like whoa this will be the
Ender yeah and then like well and it was
just like I didn't look at where the
video was in the timeline or you know
whatever like I was like only halfway
through the part like it was nothing but
Enders yeah [ __ ] insane dude yeah I
was actually really stoked to hear how
hyped everyone was on that part because
I'm just sitting back like yeah this
part was sick but like this the part
that I'm about to put out with Nike SB
and Anthony Travis filmed this one we've
also been filming it for a couple years
and this is the [ __ ] one like wow
this part is
this is what's going to get you Thrasher
skater of the year I don't know about
all that I mean I saw them speculating
about this on uh the nine Club really
they've got uh like they broke up a
whole section of the the Niger episode
it was it was you in the on the night
club recently yeah yeah and they were
like saying like
two parts back to back that that's what
they want is a lot of footage it [ __ ]
putting out a lot of footage yeah yeah I
had another one that came out earlier
this year too with disorder and right
now they're like wow yeah check it out
man I'm wearing my disorder hat yeah
that's great
dude I appreciate that so much when you
sent me the box of uh of disorder [ __ ]
man I really did
um I'm really naive to skating and I was
asking Steve yesterday
how soon did Nike come out with a
skating brand and then picking you up is
it safe to say that they they started
Nike Skateboarding
because of you to get involved or was
that like some sort of a play no Nike
has to be has been been around for a
while for a lot longer than you did
before they actually started it with
p-rod Ah that's right it was P rod and
have I told you about my P Rod or shall
I say my P rock yeah talking about my
wiener and it gets hard as a rock when I
use Bluetooth tablets why because
Bluetooth tablets have the same active
ingredient as both Viagra and Cialis
except they only cost a fraction of the
price and if you're wondering wait a
second like uh is using Bluetooth
tablets to have an outrageous boner a
lot of fun I can assure you it is indeed
a whole lot of fun
bluetooth.com use the promo code Stevo
you can get an entire month's supply of
Bluetooth tablets completely for free
all you have to pay is five dollars for
shipping man what a deal plus you don't
have to go to a doctor's office to have
some inconvenient awkward meeting to get
your prescription you just consult with
medical professionals online right at
bluetooth.com takes no time and that
month's supply of free Bluetooth tablets
is on the way you just pay five bucks
for shipping if you go to bluetooth.com
and use the promo code Stevo telling you
your boner is gonna love it now let's
talk about the other P rod
foreign
like [ __ ] maybe 20 years ago it was a
long time ago oh really yeah okay yeah
yeah you were on uh on S right for the
for a long time up until when you're on
Nike yeah maybe not 20 maybe like 15 or
something but yeah they started it with
p-rod and I remember
hearing everyone talk about it and
everyone was hating so hard like why the
[ __ ] is Nike getting it I mean you know
how scared when he was back then yeah
like why the [ __ ] is Nike getting into
skating like get the [ __ ] out of here
right and then now look at what it
became to this day it's crazy how it
changes like dude I love your [ __ ]
Nike shoes dude that's a new one right
here it's about to come out in a few
days and all your shoes are vegan
um no there's a it's a rubber material
we use
uh okay but but it's not like leather no
it's not leather yeah yeah that's right
I go into skate shops all the time I'm
like what shoes do you have that don't
have animal products like I'd say you
know I mean yeah I guess I never even
thought about like that but I guess
maybe it's tough to find durable skate
shoes that don't have [ __ ] dead cows
in them yeah because suede is the same
right the suede is leather so like I'm
constantly foot searching right like
online I'm searching like vegan skate
shoes like I'm just like an animal guy
so yeah like it's important to me and I
can assure you that out of all of the
skate shoes in the world you have the
best [ __ ] I love it did you see I
sent you the the footage of me and we
man yeah when I did that line I'm
wearing your shoes oh no ways yeah yeah
dude hell yeah yeah this is the third
one it comes out in a few days on my
birthday and this one's actually like it
has a similar feel to the second shoe
but it's just more protective and it's
more like comfortable has like more
padding right here and stuff you know
I'm like I think I've got
one of my obnoxious shoes says in the on
the insole 2021
and I think I've uh
that maybe I have I have the first two
because I got two pairs when you're
working so you're in r d with Nike
figuring out like different things you
want on the shoe or they're like hey
here here are these options pick to see
which one you want or like how involved
are you in making your own shoe yeah I
mean we start from scratch they want
they want someone like myself to be very
involved and so we go back and forth
you'll skate with a prototype like God
this kind of felt weird on my toe yeah
I'm really picky about it too like skate
shoes
Escape shoes are hard man especially for
the type of skateboarder that I am
because I flip my board a lot so I need
a lot of board feel I flip my board into
rails a lot so having that balance
between enough board feel
being thin enough with enough board feel
but also like thick and protective
enough to not like bruise your heel
right away or roll your ankle it's hard
to find that balance so it's a lot of
back and forth it's evident it's evident
that you really designed your shoe
heavily because it's so unlike other
shoes there's no
like uh it doesn't fit into like the the
norm of skate shoes it's super unique
yeah yeah and I love it man like uh I I
gotta get these new ones yeah I got you
do you get paid better sick
do you get paid better pursue or per
board is it the same country by a mile
right well it's like the same car it's
like the same option Nigel just started
his own skateboard company so
issues and now now it's board
um no I mean you definitely you
definitely make more money off shoes I
mean you make more money off your shoe
sponsor in general that's that's
normally your
highest paid sponsor in skateboarding is
she just normally like shoes
clothing energy drink and then boards
that's not how it goes how's it going
with disorder good disorder is good yeah
it's uh it's a tricky game man it is
getting into uh
getting getting into running your own
skate company like no absolutely yeah
where's your warehouse warehouse is the
same one I've had for years now it's
where my skate park is in San Clemente
yeah yeah but yeah it's been a it's been
a fun process but it's it's also like it
does get stressful and there's a lot
there's a lot to learn you know because
it's really I mean when I when I was
starting my own brand
I had offers from like other companies
and like distributions and stuff to like
help me start it and take a percentage
but then I thought about and I'm like
bro I already got this Warehouse I got
my skate park like I got good homies
around me like we really don't need much
to start this like let's just get get a
few of the homies together and make it
happen so that's what we did but I mean
there's definitely been a lot of
learning along the way and like I mean
we're always so bad with like deadlines
and stuff like like we did we were just
doing a like a Black Friday sale and
it's like the day before and we're like
hey what's up with the Black Friday sale
we're just like figuring it out right
right last minute we're like bro come on
guys [ __ ] I had the same conversation
with Scott Scott's my my business
partner with uh with March and we too
have our own Warehouse our own
fulfillment we fulfill our all our own
orders sick
um and uh we were talking yesterday like
oh dude like let's
I finally said [ __ ] Black Friday dude
[ __ ] everybody's [ __ ] trying to
hawk [ __ ] on Black Friday dude let's
give let's give people like an
undeniably attractive deal any other
time yeah that it's like Monday it's
like going out to feed the Homeless on
Thursday like I remember one one time
this this this this kid
I was helping him with sobriety stuff
and he's like oh dude we're gonna go
feed the Homeless and I'm like I think
that's kind of silly you know like on
Thanksgiving because as it turned out
there were more people out trying to
feed the Homeless than there were
homeless people there to eat food it's
just the most like cliche like I'm like
dude let's do this any other day of the
year yeah any other day yeah that's
interesting you know uh it it like it
was literally a [ __ ] crazy thing
um with that
yeah with so with the owning your own
company during the
like do you have like a chief operating
officer that like helps like run it like
yeah my boy Nathan is the main one main
homie behind the company and he's the
one handling mostly you know artwork
marketing he actually does he can do
like everything he's held around some
other companies before so he's pretty
knowledgeable and he's also a
skateboarder I actually skated something
you know those Castle contests remember
like the little like California like
kids Skate Park series back in the day
that's what I grew up skating when I was
like six seven years old and actually
skated some with him because I skated
the NorCal Division and skated against
him in the SoCal and I I smoked him I
want to do one of those contests I was
undefeated yeah dude but yeah he's one
of he's one of my oldest friends and he
helps out a lot with uh with all the
stuff but it's fun being involved
actually with like the graphics and
actually making stuff that I'm hyped on
because when I was on element for all
those years and had all this Pro
Graphics I was never really that
involved in like what was going on the
boards so yeah it's fun to be more
involved do you heat transfer a screen
print on the boards uh we started out
doing screen prints and then we've been
doing more heat transfers lately just
because it's just easier and like faster
to do yeah yeah
yeah we we all have we all three have
something in common is we love dental
floss
I saw your must-have video oh yeah
number one was dental floss or something
like that it's like damn yeah it's crazy
man like if if you don't plus you end up
with that bacteria in your mouth again
when people have that gnarly bacteria no
matter how much they brush their teeth
it doesn't go away and you're trying to
talk to them and it's like oh dude like
and they can't tell that they've got the
[ __ ] odor coming out of their mouth
and like society's just structured in a
way that it's not okay to tell somebody
yo dude you've got like [ __ ] gnarly
smell coming out of your mouth like so
nobody ever tells me it just goes on and
on for years oh yeah
it's the gnarlies
um with uh with like in the element days
like I mean I gotta believe
there was just partying going on like
like you're 16 years old you cut off
your dreads like you you know like you
you're no longer like in contact with
your dad and like it's like the preacher
kids finally are starting to party like
did you did you kind of like
you know like when your relationship
with your dad
cut off did you find yourself like now
you know like just let loose and yeah it
took me it took me about like a year or
two because I was around that time I was
very uh I was still very like socially
awkward because I never was allowed to
like really have friends growing up and
I kicked with my brothers but even them
I hadn't seen in a while so just like
being in like a public setting and like
starting to like kick it with my friends
and like go to like Little House Parties
as a teenager and stuff it took me a
while to like be a normal person it's
like be able to like conversate do
people think you're like a dick and
you're just like no I'm just socially
awkward yeah I was just quiet you know
just quiet shy but as soon as I started
to break out of that like a year or two
later and then I did have I got drunk
for my first time when I was 16 after I
won Street League Kansas City 2011 and
we were at the after party it was in a
club I don't even know who I mean who
let me in there or whatever but
um like Sheckler and like everyone was
like giving me drinks and they were just
peer pressuring me to drink and I
blacked out bro I was so drunk and I was
like so I was so un knowledgeable on
what alcohol even did to you in the
freaking everything yeah because my dad
or my mom never drank wasn't a part of
like a lifestyle growing up so I like
knew about it a little bit but like
being that drunk and then like wake up
the next day and feeling the way I did I
was so confused I was like why the [ __ ]
do I feel like this wow I feel like
I feel like I heard at some point
like
that you were like just capable of
getting super hammered and then just
waking up the next day like totally
hungover and just winning first place
and like the biggest contest yeah I did
do that a few times I don't know I don't
know how bro I don't know how I still
trip out on that to this day like it is
really crazy to think about Niger
getting wasted like that but it's even
crazier to think about your money being
wasted on overpriced shaving products I
mean come on with the vibrating razors
the the light up and it's just silly and
stupid and that's why I love
harrys.com they've got the like highest
quality five blade razor and just Sleek
classy look and it's totally affordable
I love it and man do they have the stuff
talking stuffer of the century for you
with the Harry's starter kit this has
the weighted ergonomic handle the five
blade razor the the case the travel case
to protect the razor the foaming shave
gel all of this is a 13 value but it's
yours for only three bucks if you jump
on this right now by going to harrys.com
Stevo and while you're there check out
the holiday gift boxes it's crazy these
people are my favorite and I've been
using their products for way longer than
before they became a sponsor of the Wild
Ride podcast I just believe in it and so
will you so jump on that deal by going
to harrys.com
Stevo and be quick about it because they
have very limited supply for this offer
so hurry up and let's get back to it
I was around when I was like 17 18 and
at this point like I was you know I
wasn't like drinking all the time but
you know me and the I moved out on my
own when I was 17. me and the boys moved
into this house in Huntington nice house
like a gated community and we threw
parties all the time so I would probably
drink like you know once or twice a week
and
it goes around that same time when I was
like 17. we we actually rented this
other house in Newport for the weekend
to like throw parties at but it was we
did it the same week in a Street League
and we weren't supposed to throw on the
first night we were supposed to wait
till after the contest and then of
course we end up throwing one the first
night I probably only slept like up
super hammered me and all the homies we
used to like drink so much and then I
woke up got like two hours of sleep and
then somehow went to the contest and
skated skated great
and one of the things and then part of
the even harder that night yeah I
remember like like whoever it was was
telling me about this they're like man
we've seen with like
you get like night is just a different
Beast man you know like just did it like
it's like Babe Ruth like not sleeping
the night before and just like crushing
the home run record for that Stadium or
something like that yeah for sure I mean
sometimes maybe it could help with like
the nerves and contests and kind of like
loosening you up a bit and making you a
little more like Carefree because I mean
with skating content skating and
competition is just hard it's a weird
mixture of like feelings out there like
that it's so easy to get nervous it's so
easy for your legs to just like feel
like they're not working like they
normally do because you're [ __ ]
overthinking every single thing when
it's really like dude we do these tricks
every day like you shouldn't be like
stressing on it that hard but as soon as
you get into a contest you just think
differently are you listening to the
music during the contest yeah yeah I got
airpods in listening to music that
actually helps me out a lot yeah helps
does everybody do that a lot of people
maybe like half the people I feel like
it's a new thing like in the 90s and
2000 where people listening to walk men
during competitions you know it's like
oh yes
I feel like that would help you out a
lot it definitely helps but at the same
time like my music is it has to be up
really loud to to get through all the
sound that's going on around you like in
like the arena and it is
harder to like hear your board and stuff
so that could mess with people a little
bit but for me it just helps keep me
like more focused and just like not
worrying about what's going on around me
and just more in the zone what who what
are you listening to in the in the
earphones and then are you superstitious
like if you have a good run with like a
certain song or band like do you want to
play that the next time or does it just
kind of on play or no I'll normally have
like a playlist or actually I I use
SoundCloud a lot when I skate because I
listen to a lot of house music and like
EDM like I don't know if you guys know
about that music but
um some of it is more like heavier like
hyped up like techno and stuff but for a
contest I would actually rather listen
to like more mellow house music like
like black coffee is one of the artists
he like is more like African style house
music and it's just more mellow and
really like puts you in a good Zone and
on Soundcloud they have all these long
mixes that are like an hour two hours
long so you don't even have to worry
about like switching the song a bunch
you're just like one basically just one
song the whole time and it just has
changes but you're just dialed in yeah
yeah [ __ ] I feel like I I would like to
listen to music if I played professional
sports yeah you always play better yeah
I don't know why basketball players
don't do it or it's it's weird to hear
you say that you can get nervous in a
contest when like you're just I
like the the Street League contest maybe
they're just like more frequent like
Street like you're not tripping right
it's not that I'm tripping it's just
like it's just because I care yeah I
always think about this because at this
point I've been
I've been skating Street League for 12
years now
I've won a lot of them and I feel like
at this point in my career I shouldn't
be going to a contest and stressing on
winning
especially keeping in mind the like
skateboarding is a [ __ ] very young
sport like yeah a lot of people a lot of
my fans still expect me to go out there
and win just because I've won so much in
the past but if you look at skate
contests and who is normally winning
they're on average like 21 years old
like the guy Gustavo Ribeiro he just won
the super Crown he's like 21. you know
when yuto came out on the scene like he
was winning contests when he was like 18
19 20 like those who was like
easy years of winning contests and
you're 27 now 27 about to be 28. same
thing with me my easiest years of
winning contest was actually
from like
16 to like 20.
those are the easiest years why because
your body's in better shape just because
I don't know I think I think I feel like
skateboarding just goes through these
like generations of skaters who are
really good at contests and they come on
super strong when they're young and then
they just get like better and better and
there's just like another person every
like few years it's weird and it like
never fails there's always someone new
crazy but what makes the next person
better is that he has new tricks that
nobody's ever seen or he's just Landing
every everything he tries or like what
yeah I mean consistency and yeah just
like technical tricks I mean that's
really what it comes down to nowadays
and something that I actually dislike
about contests nowadays
because
it's just so technical you know like I'm
I've always been pushing for bigger
rails and contests I want there to be a
[ __ ] 20 rail out there so you can go
you know back flip the thing and get a
high score or like flip into it and
you're gonna win the [ __ ] contest
because you're sending you're putting
your [ __ ] life on the line but
instead they keep making these like nine
ten stair rails and then and then you
you got it you got to be doing like
[ __ ] trade flip nose grinds and like
them flipping out and like flipping flip
out flipping spin out and just all this
crazy [ __ ] and I'm just like bro it's
like [ __ ]
when you're skating in the competition
how far in advance you know what trick
you're gonna do is it like all spur of
the moment spontaneous or are you like
okay I'm gonna do this one here the
night before and you're studying what
you're gonna do
yeah I mean we're we're studying as soon
as we get the course like a couple weeks
before and you already know your run and
you're practicing that somewhere else
beforehand yeah I mean a lot of yeah a
lot of the times I'll be like on the
plane on my way to the contest and like
figure out my run then
and you'll have like
a safety run and once you've locked in
like a decent score then you'll have
like the yeah the [ __ ] upgrade run
yeah yeah I mean that's that's something
that's really important and
being
good at contests is not only having the
tricks to win but also like having
backup tricks for like you know in
Street League we have the two 45 second
runs then you have like the five single
tricks and you gotta have like you gotta
have tricks that you can pull out that
are easier in case like everyone's like
falling and then you can like
for sure land your stuff and then you
gotta have harder [ __ ] in case
everyone's Landing their stuff and just
absolutely killing it so it's more than
just having the tricks that you want to
do it's about having just like a big
variety of stuff that you can pull out
and then also you always want to be able
to mix up your tricks you don't want to
go out there and do the same [ __ ] every
[ __ ] time
yeah dude wow see so you're it's just so
great like there's not even a lot of
sports where where 27 28 is like
considered old maybe there is maybe
there is yeah
didn't you ever see like if you're in
your if you're on the right side of 30
you're in you're in good shape yeah I
mean I mean yeah I wouldn't even like
say that I'm say like consider myself
old it's just like there's just always
these new little kids they're so [ __ ]
good you know but I mean I plan to still
be out there for at least another five
years competing and then
however [ __ ] many years is possible
I'm going to be out there she skating
yeah I swear I'm going to be [ __ ] six
years old at grinding rails I love it I
just [ __ ] swear bro do you who are
your favorite skaters no my favorite
skaters now
um Chris Cole has always been like my
all-time favorite him p-rod artosari
Andrew Reynolds those are the guys I
grew up watching uh my favorites like
more current skaters
um ashadware is definitely one of my
favorites
um
Braden Hoban have you heard of him he's
like a newer kid that came up throughout
the past couple years he actually all
just came so close to winning that
Street League contest and he [ __ ] I
wonder if he's uh one of Zeke's
roommates
he is from SD area yeah yeah really they
probably know each other
um but yeah he's so good he has like the
best [ __ ] kick flipping like in La
Jolla and kid flipping anything it's
crazy how about Tori pudwell I mean he's
kind of like splitting the difference
between like uh you know the all the new
yeah I know Tori's a legend she's my
favorite I've always loved him yeah I
was actually very impressed when I
watched his last video part that came
out I think like six months ago and he
had this [ __ ] nollie flip back tail
on this ledge I don't know if you saw it
I dude I did and the longest [ __ ]
ledge and it's also like pretty tall
yeah nollie flipping into a back tail on
a Ledge like that it's already hard and
you had it had to go so fast to slide
that whole thing I was shocked his part
at the end of the the plan B true video
like I just thought was I I would have
given you the gnarliest part and him the
most like technical part yeah I feel
like Tori's a good example of one of
those skaters the that is such a legend
and that has always deserved you know
just more love you know like just one of
those skaters that's like put in so many
[ __ ] hours and like been around been
Pro been putting out video parts for so
long but like they're just
I don't know some skaters just don't
really get the love that they really
deserve right just I'm saying because
there's not that much money in
skateboarding you know you would think
someone at his level should be
absolutely [ __ ] killing you know yeah
comparing it to any other sport out
there
I mean what makes somebody like kill it
and not killing the sport I mean it's
safe to say that there's hundreds right
or hundreds of pro skaters
like
of those
of those hundreds of scary I'm not gonna
say a thousand but like hundreds of pro
skaters and the overwhelming majority of
them have to work a regular job that's
[ __ ] crazy bro really for sure crazy
and like of the skaters the really do
well financially very few
and of those skaters
we're sitting with the number one
right like I mean you you're Tony Hawk
right I mean yeah yeah Sheckler well
yeah I mean I mean Tony Hawk's different
though you know it's like I don't really
compare myself to Tony in that sort of
way because he is [ __ ] Tony Hawk like
it's just yeah do you have a video game
coming out soon that we don't know about
maybe one day if anyone else is gonna
have a video game like Tony Hawk did
it'll be Niger and it's crazy too
because like you see like did were you
in a Super Bowl commercial like with
Tony and yeah like Sean White it's just
like icon status man it's rad to be
watching the Super Bowl and see Nigel
with this icon status yeah yes could
they team you up with was it Sean White
Tony Hawk I remember yeah but yeah I was
just like on that level it it's not yeah
it really has been something that's
always like just bummed me out about
skateboarding that was like why
considering how [ __ ] big
skateboarding is and like all these
brands that make so much money and like
so much so much like influence and
lifestyle comes out of what we do and
just think about like how many kids
skate all around the world but for some
[ __ ] reason there just isn't like
that much money in it to like well for
people to just live better lives like
you're saying your average pro
skateboarder like even if they don't
have to work a normal job and they just
skate they're still just kind of like
getting by that's like bro you're a
professional what you do shouldn't you
be making a Better Living for yourself
right is it crazy to see how much money
there is actually in in selling your own
board versus uh I mean is that I mean
you don't make a lot of money off the
boards and if you do it yourself you
make a lot more I mean I mean yeah we we
sell a good amount of boards at disorder
but like it takes a while to build up
any skate company it doesn't matter who
the [ __ ] is starting it it takes a while
and that's something I've always learned
like watching guys like like Shane
O'Neill start a company and stuff like
he's one of the sickest skaters ever but
it did take him a few years to really
get his company to where it's at
nowadays right I mean the the industry
standard for board royalties for a pro
skater two bucks a board right is that
still the case and
that's factoring in that they've got a
like
run the ads in this skateboard they got
all the marketing money you know and
then they gotta sell the boards to the
shop and then the shops got to mark it
up that's two dollars retail uh
do big companies like element did they
pay a different board royalty to their
skaters for the direct consumer sales or
is it just two two bucks aboard across
the
across everything it was just the same
see that's nuts that's why that's why so
many people are just starting their own
company because when you're selling
boards direct to Consumers without the
the skate shop middlemen and and you're
doing it on the back of your own social
media so without the marketing dollars
we've signed it for 100 versus 40 to the
you know right Spencers right I mean
it's crazy I I mean I I see it both ways
certainly the profit margin when you're
when you own your own company is going
to be a bigger margin but you're also
taking on all the associated expenses of
having a company and so that like
finding the balance of of uh growing it
big enough to really cash in on that
when a lot of companies I care about a
lot of skaters running companies and
they're just
selling out there on money just to keep
the thing going definitely so sorry I
feel like that's something a lot of
people don't realize and something that
I've learned with starting disorder is
there is it's not just about like
selling a thousand boards and then just
like stacking up on all this money like
there's so there's so much more than
that so many expenses and like yeah a
lot of people just don't see it that way
right yeah
um what uh
what's it like skating with Justin
Bieber
he rips he does rip and I really respect
this about him
the fact that you actually genuinely
loves skateboarding like when I skated
with him I I had met him a few times
before that but that was the first time
we really kicked it at my skate park
back a couple years ago that was when he
did the inward heel flip yeah yeah and
he was like
he he was barely even like talking to
anyone like some of our friends were
there hanging out he was like on it the
whole time just like skating and just
hyped up what year was that really likes
it
um that was I think like 2020. did the
one thing I noticed about Justin Bieber
was when we did that clown thing in
Venice yeah he that was with 2014.
so maybe he was six years worse than he
was now so he was just starting and we
were at the Venice the skate parking on
the beach right there and he came out
and he had everybody was watching him
and he wasn't good I mean he was he was
doing [ __ ] and he was eating [ __ ] and
everybody was like you know [ __ ] like
everybody was talking [ __ ] from the
crowd like looking at him and he just
didn't give a [ __ ] that wasn't my take
on it but really that wasn't my take on
it but yeah but that was the one thing I
noticed like he did not give a [ __ ]
anybody and he just kept doing this
stuff and then pick up the board and do
it again and it was like yeah I couldn't
do that I mean it was incredible he just
shut everybody out yeah what was your
take on it
he was comfortable with just skating and
having everybody filming on their cell
phones and he's not necessarily making
the tricks that he's going for and and
he was okay with that and then and that
isn't aggressive that's the same thing I
said is better worded I don't remember
anybody screaming [ __ ] or anything like
that the way you described it really I
mean nobody was hating on them they were
just paying attention to him because
everybody was hating on them because he
was Justin Bieber and he's a rich
[ __ ] 20 year old and all these people
you know what I mean it's like I I don't
remember anybody vocalizing anything
negative towards him yeah I just
remember him getting a lot of attention
well either way it's probably just so
used to that you know it was because it
was incredible daily life it was next
level yeah have you skated with Lil
Wayne I'm scared with him a couple times
too yeah he's got his own skate park he
loves skateboarding
there yeah I still need to go there yeah
like that in Florida right is it yeah in
Miami yeah he really [ __ ] loves it
too though it's crazy really [ __ ]
loves it like didn't he put out a music
video and a Tim skating
I mean I almost feel like part of the
reason why you stopped putting out so
much music was because you started
skating and he was just so hyped on that
that's cool yeah it's great and then and
he you know like he I think it Lil
Wayne's approached skating is like
super healthy and that he doesn't care
how his skating Stacks up against like
all the footage out there he's just
competing for with himself to get better
than he was before yeah yeah that's like
I I'm so jealous of bam like when when
jackass started like you know I had kind
of given up on on my skating I was just
like man I'm not I'm not good enough at
skating I'm just gonna like do all this
crazy stunt [ __ ] and be in skateboard
videos not skating and then you know we
get the jackass thing going and Bam did
both you know and I look back on those
ears and think why did I uh
compare myself to everybody else I could
have just stuck with it and just worried
about outskating myself yeah if I just
try to outskate myself then I'm a happy
guy I know I feel like I hear that a lot
I feel like a lot of people get
discouraged easily and they're like oh
I'm not not good enough at this so I
don't want to do it when I always tell
people like you really don't have to be
an insanely good skateboarder to have
fun with it like if you can if you can
ollie and like maybe do a kickflip and
like if you can grind if you can grind
some Ledges grind some little rails you
will have a lot of [ __ ] fun yeah yeah
what about when like you're you're at a
point
where
like
let me show you said you're gonna be
grinding rails when you're 60. and I do
not doubt that for a second but like
at a certain point when all the little
kids that come up and they're ripping so
hard and you like
you
just kind of get pushed out of the game
you know you get aged out like do you
have
like an idea of what you want to be
doing like when you're when you're 40
you're like
40
40 like yeah I mean obviously I won't be
like sending it like I am nowadays yeah
I plan to like be just you know more
mellow lifestyle in general at that
point like hopefully have a family and
stuff I was having 40. so I'm not going
to want to go put my life on the line
every day right yelling at your kid to
do the mega yeah yeah
I'm gonna be taking my kid out he's
gonna be like three years old but don't
jump on this [ __ ] 20 real bro come on
yeah I mean I remember
um but I remember seeing Ryan Sheckler
say something or other about like how uh
his his mentality is like to his career
he's like yeah I just want to kill it
right now like I want to be able to
[ __ ] retire when I'm 30. you know I
remember hearing shackler say that
you're like dude I want to [ __ ] have
enough money to retire when I'm 30. and
I just thought that was [ __ ] rad you
know to be realistic about how like
there's only so long that you can really
get away with being at the top of the
skateboard I mean it depends what you
mean me and as far as like retiring if
he's talking about retiring is like like
not skating anymore then I think that's
like okay sorry he didn't say retire
even more contest contest he said he
said he wanted it to be set for life not
necessarily retired like I'm putting
words in his mouth he didn't say he just
said I wanted like you know I don't have
to work after I'm 30. I don't want it to
work I want to be set yeah I mean that
you know that that is a good goal you
know everybody wants that but I think
the cool thing about skateboarding is
like
if you retire like the only the only
time I've I'm ever gonna announce that
I'm like sort of retiring is going to be
retiring from contests it's never
actually retiring right right I mean
it's like I'm I when I'm 40 50 I I want
to be still putting out a little video
Parts even if I'm just skating a little
[ __ ] curbs and [ __ ] right I'll still
put out filming stuff when I'm like 50
years old like why I mean Tony Hawk's
doing the same thing big time how about
Jamie Thomas dude yeah if I can this is
48 tricks on his 48th birthday was so
rad man I had to hit him up on IG like
dude like you just inspired the [ __ ] out
of me yeah that dude is 48 and [ __ ]
ripping yeah like he's not like he is
properly [ __ ] ripping man yeah I did
and you know what else about Jamie
Thomas like I remember I met him in year
2000 before jackass came out and I was
just like this schmucking big brother
magazines like jumping off apartment
buildings into pools and [ __ ] and uh he
was on top of the world you know that
was like the you know maybe he hadn't
even done the leap of faith yet but he
was like like welcome to hell like I
mean he was at on the top of the world
skateboarding and when I met him he was
like like you know treated me good you
know like he like he had he had time he
was like I just remembered like just
really respecting like I I respect the
hell out of Jamie Thomas man yeah where
were you guys too it was in Tampa it was
the the Tampa Pro I did the stupid thing
where I lit myself on fire in the middle
of the street course
they stopped everything they're like
okay now everyone like clear the course
like
some guy this button that's gonna light
himself on fire and uh the other foot of
that yeah it came out in the Tampa
prayer video yeah
and and Jamie Thomas was super cool to
me I remember derdick was like
killing it that that was 2 000 22 years
ago man yeah it's so crazy how at times
goes It goes on and on and I'm 48. I'm
the same age as Jamie Thomas yeah those
old Tampa contests were sick I've been
trying to tell those guys that they need
to do a throwback contest with like a
similar that that style course they used
to make like the thick like fat Square
rails and all the big pyramids and all
the stickers all over the ramps I was
like bro throw it back yeah I mean dude
the the Tampa like for for how like
corporate skateboarding has gotten you
know like with ESPN and with you know
like Nike like all this like
skateboarding's gotten so mainstream and
and in so many ways corporate that it
really
like makes that Tampa spot so special it
does yeah yeah it makes that Tampa
contest the pro and the am like
the most legit contest there is yeah I
know it's so sick that they're still
keeping it going yeah and uh dude I mean
they just had the Tampa Am it was insane
yeah like the pocket [ __ ] that AMS are
doing
I know I've been paying attention to
this for the for the past couple years
like am am winning runs compared to the
pro winning ones and the am runs are
honestly gnarlier a lot of the times
it's [ __ ] crazy
why is that because you're just going
for it and they're [ __ ] they're just
so [ __ ] hungry bro they're just so
hungry they they come from like Japan or
from the other side of the world and
their mind is so set on doing good at
this [ __ ] contest like they're so
hungry
um though yeah the last kid who just
wanted did some crazy [ __ ]
yeah the the best trick too man like
it's it's nuts man I love skateboarding
dude I always maintain I say it all the
time that like everything that that
really matters to me I feel like I
learned from skateboarding you know like
just with like dedication like
persistence sacrifice you know like
skateboarding like I started in in 1985.
and
um sorry I started in 1986 I think but
whatever dude I was 11 years old and um
you know I went to see the first Back to
the Future movie and and it was uh
Michael J Fox like holding onto the car
and they had all the pro skaters like
stunt double as Michael J fox and I was
just so stoked on it like I I literally
just let walked out of the movie theater
and found a skateboard I knew where I'd
seen one and I just went to it and I
just started skating and that that movie
in 1985 like created a boom of
skateboarding like uh every [ __ ] kid
in the world had a skateboard under
their tree for like that Christmas and
like in a very short time after that
Christmas like
95 of those kids realize how [ __ ]
hard it is how much it hurts when you
fall down and like it's just like this
what the skateboard is to me is this
device that weeds out [ __ ] and
quitters it really does crazy like
skateboarding isolates a type of person
that is so
[ __ ] determined you know just the raw
determination just the will to [ __ ]
work towards a goal at any cost yeah
like the ultimate sacrifice the amount
of work that goes into it and like the
way that it
kind of pits you against Authority
because everything that you skate you're
[ __ ] vandalizing you know like you're
not allowed to do it anywhere you're
made to be like some kind of a [ __ ]
criminal element you know so like it
just breeds this intense Independence
and this [ __ ] this this person that
skateboarding special Plus on top of
that there's no other activity that
lends itself to the video camera like
skateboarding guys so skateboarders got
such a a jump start on video production
and you know there's so many of us in
it's [ __ ] legit like Hollywood
because of skateboarding yeah yeah I
know skateboarding's trippy man I like I
I ask myself sometimes when I'm out
there like just [ __ ] destroying my
body like trying to jumping down some
set of rail for hours and I'm just like
like what I asked myself like why am I
doing this like why do we put our bodies
and our minds through this much pain and
stress and just like like what is the
reason and so
what I've really came to the conclusion
of throughout the past like year or two
of like thinking this way and especially
throughout filming this last video part
that I'm about to put out
is like it's more of uh it's more of
like a need than a want it's more like I
really need to be out here doing this
like this is who I am as a person and
like I need this like Challenge and this
this like excitement of trying these
tricks and Landing them and like setting
your mind to something and making it
[ __ ] happen like it really is
something that you need in your life
after you've had it for a while instead
of just being like Oh I want to go do
this trick that's why my part I'm
putting out it's called need that nice
yeah
um like so you were filming both parts
over the last two years yeah like did
you
were you obligated on some filming
sessions that you were filming for the
Nike part and other times you weren't or
were you able to like choose how to
divvy up the footage like this I'll put
in that part this I'll put in this part
no no I was it was all separate like out
days filming with Ty I mean sometimes Ty
would be on the sessions with ant too
but most of the time like every time ant
was filming we were filming for his part
um I always knew the main part and the
part I was gonna put my most effort into
was going to be the Nike part with ant
because the last part I put out a few
years ago the tildew
gnarliest part ever yeah it was a gnarly
part and it came out really sick but you
know Ty Evan Ty Evans has his really
like high quality yes yes demographics
type of filming and after putting that
out I was like hmm like I want my next
big part to be just more raw Street
skating part so that's what this one is
more just like classic skate part yeah
Ty Evans is like all up on like gimbals
and like yeah he's got his like 500 000
out camera on the front of his van
filming from and man it's it's sick
though it really is
I'm really thankful for Ty because he
him making the shine on part and the
Till Death part it really made like a
different type of video part that
separates from all your parts from like
looking too similar you know he really
like made something different and
special and I really respect that it's
it's kind of like when like with Tori
his his true part and then the part that
he just put out like it's it's hard to
say one's better than the other you know
like
and uh you know I mean it's been a while
since I went to till death but
you know I can't sit here and say that
that uh
you know shine on until death like which
one's better I mean like I guess shine
on like does take it to another level
with like that [ __ ] fakie 50 50. is
that the same uh rail that you did the
figgy 50 50 down that Pat Duffy in in
the questionable video it seems real
similar no no it's not the same one I
know which one you're talking about
though yeah yeah it seems real similar
to that rail like uh the one that the
d-way board slid and and uh
SD yeah yeah those dudes are legends
really like opened up like the I think
those were really the first dudes
hitting King drills like that like
they're really open like unlock the
whole like new side of like
skateboarding it's crazy yeah I mean
dude I'll tell you on this podcast the
skin was the only skaters we've had were
Tony Hawk Ryan Sheckler Danny Way Tory
pudwell and Niger
yeah it's like pretty pretty high level
like Mount Rushmore yeah the super Mount
Rushmore it's sick I'm sick so uh and as
we're recording this today is Black
Friday we both missed the ball
yeah
we dropped the ball we missed the day
like uh is there anything that we want
to uh tell people about with for
disorder uh disorder you know like I
mean like just go to where are people
buying disorder boards at uh right now
we are mainly still selling our stuff
online
disorderskateboards.com but actually
just as of recently we've been getting
out more wholesale into more skate shops
cool do you have a sales rep that gets
you into shops yeah yeah I do we need
that yeah I got some reps that get us
out there and yeah I mean I think uh you
know it's a lot of it's a lot of
learning along the way but my main goal
for for disorder is just to keep growing
it create a create a sick team sick sit
crew guys which I think we're doing a
pretty good job at so far and really
just create a lot of content a lot of
videos yeah as soon as I'm better I want
to put out some more parts with disorder
and I'm always I'm a good team manager
so I'm always on the on the younger guys
about that too I'm like all right let's
get this guy
come on yeah that's sick dude yeah cool
so uh so we're gonna encourage
absolutely everybody to go to
disorderskateboards.com yeah and support
the cause yes sir it's uh damn remember
when I when I was a kid
skaters didn't
own and run skateboard companies you
know like it's it's there's something
special about that like uh and and to
see the skaters
like owning it you know that's worth
supporting man it's worth uh supporting
Niger and um what what other [ __ ] we got
the the shoe drops got the shoe dropping
soon we got the part coming out
I said that's the the that puts it
together what okay yeah yeah the oh
you're you're sorry you're coming
tomorrow
check this out when I was like I've
watched Nigel's shine on part so I hit
him up uh on Instagram just to be like
dude Bravo man [ __ ] like unbelievable
work and uh and I just said do you want
to promote shine on on the podcast like
uh search It Shine On Niger it's so epic
and he goes yeah sure I'll do your
podcast but but uh but you gotta come to
my premiere on Saturday
like deal yeah I didn't ask you anyway
dude what an honor man yeah and uh I
didn't even know about the second part
I'm like wait hold on a second you just
put this out this part that's [ __ ]
earth-shattering called shine on and you
have another part is going for Thrasher
skaters yeah Dad I
Thrasher's been
like uh
skating on thin ice with me man
they're bad they better uh they better
recognize all right I'm out it's all
good you know I I mean the way I think
about it is I'm still young enough and
I'm still so [ __ ] motivated that I
still have so many other years that I'm
gonna be out there sending it and
putting out these video Parts I don't
even I don't even stress on stuff like
that I just want to keep [ __ ] being
motivated to go out there and
all right well we got Nike disorder
Still Still skating for monster monster
yup Monster Energy yeah
um Diamond Supply yeah Diamond those are
the homies and uh what about your grip
uh no grip sponsor no grips I have a lot
of sponsors actually I just like being
able to like skate what I what I want to
skate you know what size shoe are you
[Laughter]
is there anything else we want to
promote ah no I mean mainly mainly just
the footage I hope you guys like the
footage
you guys dude check out shine on man
[ __ ] and uh dude and and the um the life
on video for Barracks was a good one
yeah it was really cool man a good like
full-on it was rad because it was like
your life story but in the context of
your video Parts yeah so so many funny
[ __ ] stories and situations popped
into my mind while talking about that
yeah it was great yeah yeah but dude
this was killer man and I was super
excited yeah about uh
I was just so excited about to talk to
you and um now I ended it
ladies and gentlemen how rad is Niger
Houston oh and if you haven't seen his
new part the shine on and the need that
Nike part then you don't even know how
rad he is you have no idea and let me
just say this to Thrasher magazine one
more time
Saudi guys skater of the year
or I'm out
but I'll never be out with people who
stick around to the end of the wad ride
podcast my beloved street team maybe if
you guys could do the old street team
trick and uh throw up a post with Nigel
tagged to let him know how [ __ ] rad
he is man I really enjoyed that a lot
and I love you guys thanks so much
oh and check out this [ __ ] theater
dude
so rad